two
well well well welcome to the families
reunion hanukkah
in the studio
in honor of the holidays we have back
the don arc herself donna klein mother
of all butterflies
good to be back
you're like you're like venus coming out
of the clam shell but if you had
butterfly wings oh god you know
it's been fun it's been a lot of fun i
have an update and everything yeah show
them your notes i mean i have all kinds
of notes i'm always taking my mom
brought here they sho don't know you
don't have to well just show the
quantity i mean she got like 20
flashcards like she's preparing for a
spelling goddess no no no i just have a
bunch of things that i wanted to share
okay you know
all right
you take it seriously yeah i do i do i
do and of course gary cline the enemy of
beach balls everywhere
[Applause]
how many beach balls have you put to
their grave since their last episode
i've lost count yeah
i've been to a bunch of dodger games so
i had many opportunities to kill beach
balls yeah and i noticed you did take
the swift's army knife that we used for
that segment right you took it
i asked and you said you could take it
yeah well yeah so you did take it i did
but have you brought it to any dodger no
they won't let you i couldn't sneak it
in oh there i didn't want to go to any
extended kind of trickery to sneak it in
there so you can't so
that's interesting back in the day you
could bring the swiss army knife now you
can't yeah since it's another thing that
got ruined from 911 oh please can't
smuggle deadly weapons into sporting
events anymore geez
deadly to beach ball that's
right well you could put a little hole
in someone if you stabbed them with that
sure yeah the corkscrew especially yeah
god
yeah and that one person we caught
smoking at the dodger game you almost
put a hole oh my yeah with my tongue
right lacerated them with my tongue well
he yelled at them okay
figuratively
yeah
all right well what a what a great show
we've got you know
we've basically planned the best
possible show today
full of i'm excited competitions and
games let me just lay it all out here
first of all today's episode is
sponsored by curology and hbo max who we
love so well thank you thank you
um
today
we have two segments planned
first of all a hanukkah cook-off segment
if you of those of you guys who are not
familiar with hanukkah tradition
there's a thing called a potato latke
yep which is basically a potato pancake
some people call it
it's like a deep or it's like a fried uh
potato flour egg mixture
correct traditional and uh my mom has
been challenging me she's been stepping
to me
i better win
well i've never cooked a lava oh good
and you've been cooking them for years
and they're very good i had some
recently yeah you know you've got some
swag yeah
would you say you have latkes swag i i'm
pretty you know i think i think
some holidays you have to be over the
age of 30 to be able to do it well
i'm over 30.
well you know like you have to be doing
it and it takes yeah to make a perfect
luck you have to have been doing it at
least for years and years and years well
we'll be the judge of that today yes
because we're going to do a blind
judging panel to see who is the lodka
god
the latka god okay and by the way we
also have a bonus word today
uh oh i got it gary remind me
the bonus word is swag oh okay do you
know what swag is i do define it
swag is goodies that you get
swag
isn't it like when they go to the that's
actually technically right when they go
there i was thinking of though
yeah when you go to award shows and they
give all right that is swag
that's not the way the kids use the word
swag
i think you can also pronounce it schwag
no there's no there's no c schwag no
when i was in the industry that's you
mean like swag all kinds of swag mean
like weed
no
swag or swag
on the word people don't say schwag yeah
do that
olivia do people say schwag
she says she has never we asked olivia
because she's the gen z she's the zoomer
she olivia gave the x on that one dad
she said never olivia am i right about
the the definition of swag yeah like
swagbucks yeah but that's not what i
mean okay what do you so what do you
mean so um swag means like
ian
olivia come to find swag for us please
it's like uh having swagger style yeah
style you could have you can have swag
someone can have swag yeah that's i
guess there's a dual definition then i
suppose well that's the one we're
looking for today is swag you just go
swag you have to say like when you walk
and he's got yeah he's got swag
does that come from swaggy the guy that
did wasn't me
that's shag oh shaggy jeez
yeah from swaggy uh from the famous song
uh
uh schwarzenschmie
i don't know yeah that one
so um
so and you have to say it like swag
can you do that swag
that's good all right so first so we've
got that that's gonna be fun and then
the ultimate you know the boomer uh we
had
iconic moment of the show is you trying
to put an attachment on an email
if you recall that oh that was horrible
so bad so we're having a boomer off
between you and dad we have got the new
halo game and he's been cheating back
there
a little bit yeah he's been cheating a
little he's been toying around with the
controller a little bit abey's abi
you're babysitting my dad yeah no he's
he's good he's just looking at the menu
well
all right okay so we got the new halo
game we set up a network where it's
going to be one on one
whoever i guess gets a first kill or
best of three i don't know how bad this
is i think i think just one kill yeah it
depends how bad it is because it could
be that one kill probably what's the
name of the game halo halo
okay
it's a religious game
it's about heaven and angels right
heaven and angels that you kill each
other
to meet your maker you can pick your
favorite prophet between moses
jesus you can pick um well i won't be
picking the archangels or whatever
or you can play as satan and uh cerberus
the three-headed
oh
hell and you try to kill that sounds
pretty good
okay so the winner gets a
magnificent gift so you are going to
want to play
high stakes game i'm very competitive so
i'm going to win i want to win no matter
what okay
so that's what we have planned today but
before we begin let's let's light the uh
hanukkah candles
ready wrong side
oh
first of all no no you have to light
this one and this one has to light all
of them
oh i can't light them all no here like
like this okay so we like the middle one
yeah
ethan how did you you don't know i don't
know
anyway what the heck blame them they're
the ones here a child is only
you know a child is only as good as uh
please
[Music]
yeah this is upbringing okay are we
gonna stay together
you gotta keep it going until all the
candles are lit
wow
okay and many more
wait is this how do i get this on here
[Applause]
help you out there let you uh-oh it so
oh i think you have to stick it
it's the traditional post hanukkah
menorah lighting yeah hanukkah is over
that's clever that it's stuck on there
with just the wax
because usually those holes we were
always digging out the wax yeah i kind
of like this version better i like that
too um okay forgive me but uh i'm not
doing that again so we're just gonna
light this one up for this one just god
look the other way the maccabees are are
rolling in their graves yeah what's
interesting about hanukkah to those
americans who aren't super familiar is
that
oh
man
where's the miracle now hey you got it
you got it what's interesting about that
i learned about hanukkah when i lived in
israel for five years yeah is that it's
actually a it's like the most minor
holiday
in the entire jewish religion like in
israel they don't care about hanukkah at
all right
they just eat jelly doughnuts it's like
okay they're not even that good yeah
well you know we we have to compete with
christmas all these kids these yeah
that's because christian children get
these beautiful gifts and our kids are
going what
yeah they used to give we can top that
we get eight gifts ha when i was young
my parents used to give me money for
each night like pennies pennies
66
sorry i asked i was just you didn't have
to ask no it's okay i don't care you're
66 i know you're so young
you are you youthful and you look so
good my mom was so worried about how she
was looking and she looks fantastic by
the way my dad on the other hand
oh
goodness me no you look great too dad
you guys really do i mean you're old as
hell what are you like eight seventy
nine
no you're like seven right yeah he said
i don't like a day over 71.
well i was saying people think i'm 50 so
you don't look 50. people say that when
i say i'm 36 people go what i thought
you were 50.
every time
that's okay
you know so how have you guys been
since the uh
the end of frenemies i mean uh it's been
a long time almost our last step
families families well did i say friends
you did
families families families families
families families families families
families
family families family families
yeah so um
how have you guys been since the end of
families
good good i've been you know i always
try to keep busy and with projects and
things that i'm doing and
and um hanging out with my girlfriend
you're working on well i can't
say oh my god because it's a surprise i
know what you're doing you're making but
i don't want i know what you're doing i
don't want
[Music]
i've already said his name everybody
knows his name
oh i thought you guys said you were
going to change it though because of the
backlash i thought you said no we well
so yeah we were going to name our we
said we're naming our son how does how
does he know that he's making you did
the same thing for theodore
so how did she know i was going to do
well my my mom acts like it's like the
biggest secret ever she goes i got to go
home early i'm working on this huge
project but
i didn't say it in front of you
i was like you're making a blanket for
bruce i know what you're doing and it's
fine it's like
so much for my secret
well that's what i've been doing i've
been i've been working on that and
i've been doing can i say what i've been
doing cameos well i guess i just said it
of course you can i i'm doing cameos and
why did you say like that
i don't know i just i don't know
but i've been having a lot of fun i've
been having a lot of fun
and uh because i was going to make fun
of you for plugging it maybe yeah
immediately with those cameo plugs and
i've been on tick-tock i've been doing
tick-tock tuesday
i've unleashed i've opened a can of
worms oh my god who was i talking to
with abe was it you or was it was it
zach i am um or maybe dan i am a junkie
for tick-tock
yeah you become addicted i opened the
can of worms oh my god now like we were
having a hanukkah at my house my mom's
whipping out her phone she's recording
it for tick tock she's worse she's worse
than any influencer now god it's it's so
much fun though
yeah and you pushed back i was like mom
you got to get on tick tock trust me and
you were pushing back remember my god
god knows what it would be like if i was
a young person these days i'd be on
basically what you're doing yeah well
sounds like not like will you admit that
i was right about tick tock it's a lot
of fun
that's not you admitting i was right
okay you were right you were right oh
here it is let's see what she's been up
to oh no don't do my last one people i
look like this is the video play this
all right here we are
yeah ready it's dreidel dreidel dreidel
i made it
let's go
[Applause]
i didn't want to film teddy but he was
there singing along he's so cute
yes so anyway we're we stopped showing
theodore's face because we he's like at
school and we don't want people
but you know we got to be my mom's
whipping out the phone all willy-nilly
and we're like you know i mean no i
didn't film him yeah you didn't but you
know
i wouldn't i wouldn't put that up if
this you were about you were about to
fight but
but i've been having a lot of fun dad
what's your take on this mom's social
media addiction now
she's a big influencer oh no she hardly
she's bringing home the bacon now hardly
yeah she enjoys it she really takes it
to heart she spends a lot of time with
it
and is very invested in her tick-tock
success yeah i want to give everyone
really good advice so i really
you know think and it really pays well
too tick-tock oh yeah i think two cents
per hour she's earned like 57 cents yeah
500 tick-tocks
yeah well you do it for love of the game
yeah obviously i'm not going to be you
know
buying a new house with 17
no
has it caused a strain on your guys's
relationship have you felt more distant
from her now that she's all on tick-tock
all the time um no no more of a strain
than usual yeah you got easily yeah
we're always friends
that's right it's actually helped uh
it's helped us tremendously i don't have
to talk to her anymore
i'm putting words in your mouth uh
making it maybe yeah get those words out
of my mouth
well you know
dad loves to watch all the sporting
events yeah and you know me i never sit
down until my head hits the pillow so
there's always stuff that i'm i'm doing
well
here's a tick tock we we found that was
a little questionable i have to be
honest you're sending out messages i am
that are potentially very dangerous
really what was that i'm gonna have to
call you out today mom uh oh
was that when i went to court
no oh
but that well no but that was funny
well we tell keep telling my mom don't
tell people where you are
she goes to court and she's waiting to i
was doing my civic duty hey guys i'm at
this exact location and i'll be here for
several hours we're like mom don't tell
people exactly where you are well
there's like actual nazi groups who have
done like death threats on bomb threats
on well i won't do that anymore i won't
do they're gonna take in your ass and
i'm gonna have to pay to get you free oh
god no i won't do that what are the what
are there are you ready uh-oh
what did i do
yeah just watch because this is this is
this is pretty messed up stuff really
yeah you're gonna have to be more
careful
i can't promoting witchcraft
does that sound oh the woman was a she
was a she was a witch you're promoting
witchcraft now i wasn't promoting it i
was just saying that i understand that
witchcraft isn't like witchcraft that
it's just like a pagan holiday
okay let's see all right
hey alex this is donna from families i
got this message from your friend
madison
and she wanted me to wish you a very
merry christmas
happy holidays happy new year
she also told me to make sure i tell you
to keep slay queening and reading those
slay cleaning
i have no idea some people ask me to to
say all kinds of weird things
she's a witch
no no no not slake that's regicide
yeah that's that's that's not right slay
queening he means she wants me to kill
people yeah she's she wants you to kill
queens i mean that that is high trees
slay queening i didn't
well you know what then i didn't realize
that that's what she was asking me i
think it says like slay comma
queen in other words
yeah keep doing it you're oh
yeah that's how i took it i thought she
was telling you to do that no
no no okay watch it again all right
let's keep watching like you read a
snake in the grass
you know i understand that you are a
witch and that you love reading tarot
cards um my granddaughter loves to do
that that was so reminds me of when i
was young my girlfriends we always used
to get together on halloween and we
would go trick-or-treating and of course
cause havoc we were around 12 and we
always used to come back to my friend
maureen's house her mother used to let
us spend the night and we would do
seances and read tarot cards you're
doing i mean
it was fun black magic oh ethan it's
just things girls do oh god
i was 12 years old and it was fun hey
all right
and we used to do this levitation thing
where one of the girls would sit in a
chair and we'd four of us would would be
around here richard i'm wearing a
classic yeah nice
you might call that swag
well you didn't but you told me not to
use it that way yeah i did
but you might call it swag
okay
um if you look old i look fat as [ __ ]
[Music]
this turtleneck doesn't do me any favors
i feel like makes my face look massive
bro i look like uh who's that the
guidance counselor from south park doc
mr mackey
where his head is huge what were you
gonna say i was gonna say you know your
brother is getting getting married in
june
yes i know that and i want you to look
really dapper okay and have some swag
when you wear your suit oh
okay
and so
i think that's a dub yeah that's a dub
right there yeah and um
i just think you should you know
you should look good you want me to lose
weight yeah so you i think that's what
she's saying yes
are you saying fat people can't look
good
no no but i because you said gliscor
battles were on the table okay i i think
that maybe some people think
perhaps
that i look
young or good because
i'm slender and i can wear
clothing so fat people don't look good
and young
no but i think that sometimes weight can
age someone so you're saying fat people
look old
maybe you're better off tackling this
from a
health perspective okay let's go from
the whole i like the health okay
you know i just want you to look ethan
oh you would you said you look good
again ethan you are so handsome i got to
tell you guys i don't know when ethan
was little oh [ __ ] and we ate here we go
oh my god he was so beautiful you were
stuck and you tell the story and let's
just weigh in you tell this story and
then we'll do a poll afterwards if
people think it's true or not no it is
absolutely
fake of your imagination
okay well that's high school that's high
school but when ethan we were in
elementary school and at the end of this
the the school year the teacher had
slide pictures of all the children
playing and you were on this jungle gym
and they they put you up there and i
tell you you could hear a pin drop you
were so gorgeous
you were people used to stop me okay so
hold on so my mom's story is that in
kindergarten he's so handsome they were
showing pictures but i look like a dork
bro
okay but wait listen to this story she
goes you were so gorgeous
everyone in the auditorium was brought
to
silence in awe of how beautiful you were
you were just oh my god you were
gorgeous you could hear a pin drop
people were awesome you're a handsome
guy so he sounds like your mother
look at that face come on
look at you
wow i just think that's like a quarter
of ethan
you mean nothing is that when he went to
israel
yeah that was in israel that's when you
i mean you were always a toothpick
always and now what am i
well you're not a toothpick if i was if
i was a toothpick then what am i now
more like a log no
you're the whole damn log
no but i just think that you would look
so sharp and have swag it's really hard
for me to lose weight because of the
medicine i'm on
well you know what i've said that to you
i just i started gaining a lot of weight
when i started taking the lux bro but
it's really good for me so i i don't
want to stop isn't there some other
medication that can do the trick because
i've noticed that too since you've been
on that medication
i don't know i don't want to change
medicine when it's working well for me
you know like my mental health is more
important than yeah but you know what i
don't want you to um yeah did you know
on the right that's what i could that's
what i looked like two years ago on the
right and no that's not what she looked
like two years ago i tried
no that does it does not look like you
that's giga chad ethan
that's
i mean it looks like someone
that you can tell that's not you okay
fair enough she got she did she took the
dub on this one yeah it's real here
here's another one oh yeah that's me
with casey neistat
well i recognize casey neistat it's like
the guy who's the other guy
yeah it's a giga chad ethan oh there you
go there you are there you are look at
you all right so uh oh my god so anyway
yeah i mean i'm the whole damn law if
you're if you were a twi if you were a
toothpick you're the whole damn tree now
and the words my dad
yeah you're the whole damn forest
right the whole forest
yeah
i just i just i don't know i just yeah
no i just wish there was another
medication because you know you say it's
good for your mental health but you know
i don't it's not good
for your physical health you do this you
go you go it's not good
it's not good for your physical health
no i i know you know i mean
i i
i get it that it's helping you but i
just wish there was another medication
because i i have noticed that my
medication okay has done this to you
last night i had a white sauce pizza
yes i heard that that you were ordering
pizza i was watching the video or your
podcast
sanctioned pizza ordering because she's
briggs oh we got white sauce pizza with
um white sauce pizza [ __ ] yeah dude
how was they do alfredo sauce it was
okay i can't i regretted it yeah
red you gotta have the red sauce yeah
well no sometimes the white sauce is
like an elf
all right well anyway i'm fat my mom's
old
everything's the same as it was when we
left
um but i'll tell you what has changed
what has changed the [ __ ]
[ __ ] butterflies have made a
colossal comeback
and we have to we know why let's be
honest we know why
the the butterflies have made a comeback
the don ark well after record low
monarch butterflies return to california
donna is a national heroes the deadline
of this
mom what do you think about this i think
it's wonderful do you take any
no
no there's a lot of people that have
been uh on the bandwagon you know
trying to promote the health of monarchs
and been screaming from the rafters i
just joined i wonder if you're a hero
voices
though because i feel like you got a lot
of uh those
uh poisonous deadly poisonous milkweeds
in the ground
i think she's mentioned in that article
actually
no
you know what i just think that um
you know i was i was reading a couple
articles and some of the scientists were
saying that a big part of the comeback
is because of the drought
oh the drought is good for them well
they because the warmer weather you know
because the monarchs can't fly if the
temperature gets too low
and so they've been able to to you know
breed and continue on because it's not
the original butterfly you know it's
it's like three generations it takes to
get to their
to their uh
you know destination let me say this
last year there was only 2 000 monarch
butterflies spotted yeah this year over
a hundred thousand
yeah and they gave those butterflies and
they're still counting you know what uh
the mayor of of mountain view uh
california yeah
she is collab she was collaborating with
um
with uh google
and they they they uh donated thirty
thousand dollars that's all they could
muster well no no they've also donated a
million beforehand okay good but but
they you know they're they're putting
several acres aside and they're planting
all kinds of you know they're making
like a weigh station for these the
milkweed the milkweeds and and the and
the flowers so we love google for that
well you know as dad pointed out google
you know the butterflies migrate and
that's like right in their backyard so i
think it's i think it's good that they
put their money to good use sure yeah
i'm actually going to surprise mom with
a trip up to like the paso robles areas
which is where they nest
because there are tens of thousands of
them when you say surprise what do you
mean well now i'm not surprised okay
maybe not a surprise no she knew about
it but you nodded like you knew so uh
yeah find a vicious dog friendly hotel
where we can stay with wallace yeah yeah
and and in in this mountain view
california they have this uh library and
they give out seeds for free oh that's
nice so they give you like 15 seeds
which probably uh
translates to three plants you know and
they you can ask for milkweed or you can
ask for a fruit tree
or you know flowers
you whatever
that's good it's good for the cross
pollinators as well
we love the butterflies yeah it's been
it's been awesome if only people cared
about the homeless as much as they care
about the butterflies
well
they're not pretty
and they certainly it helps when you can
you know they call up not beautiful they
call a group of butterflies a flutter
isn't that a pretty name that is
beautiful you know what they call a a
group of homeless and skid row
oh lord i'm not even gonna give an
answer to that don't do that just the
premise itself is the joke yeah
anyways i just think it's wonderful and
and you know
just a little uh information i don't
know if anybody
knows this but um you know how you count
butterflies i mean they can't sit there
and count one two three
they do it in clusters
so a cluster can be
one to three or there can be thousands
in a cluster and so you just figure out
okay this is how much it is so they go
like five they're just estimating yeah
right that's how they that's how they
count
and uh yeah so monarch butterflies saw
an increase of 3 500 in pismo beach
pacific grove california saw zero
monarch butterflies in 2020 but of this
year
13 000 yeah 2021 ranks among the top
three for monarch populations in pacific
grove in the past 10 years
scientists say it's too early to
determine
what is causing the monarch resurgence
but we know the truth well it was donna
well
i'm i'm happy to join in i really am
there's a lot of people that have have
been into it and uh oh uh here's another
fun fact i learned butterflies can hear
they can yes there's the they if you
take a a little uh microscope
or um
you know
if you look really close there's like
little hairs like long little hairs by
their head what do they listen to
and all everything that's around them
that no seriously they can hear like
scientists were suspicious
and they've actually been doing
experiments like they were cutting off
the hair and you could tell by by
how they react they're doing um
experiments on life but well they just
cut the hair i mean they're encouraging
those little hairs with a scissor a
scissor there's a tiny little butterfly
uh well i don't know
all i know is they're i'm sure
they don't feel that they don't they do
it so they don't feel pain speaking of
pain can i share something about you
wait speaking of pain yeah can i share
something i want to share something with
you oh okay
what if what could happen if you defend
butterflies in mexico you heard about
this oh gosh
did someone else die this poor guy was
you know a donark in mexico fighting for
the butterfly butterfly lives
is this a new a new
a quarterly invite you know two guys
have been killed right right right right
yeah i thought there was another one you
were talking about let me read the uh
it's horrible
[Music]
butterfly here is the world's biggest
sanctuary called el rosaire the world's
biggest most beautiful today the
butterflies are flying in search of
water as they do every day they look for
flowers and then go back to where they
live about 200 meters from here
[Music]
el rosario
is that one of the guys that was killed
or is that just some random
this is one of the guys who was uh they
have so many butterflies that they count
them in hectares
there's so many why don't you you should
take a trip down there
it sounds dangerous i was gonna say i
don't know
we've had we love mexico but we had
plenty of mexico living there for
students i would go back if i thought it
was safe i loved it yeah the last time i
went there i got shook down at the
airport and then we vowed never to go
there again
did they really do that to you yeah we
went there me and ela went there for
like my birthday oh i remember like uh
we brought camera equipment uh
and they s they seized our camera
equipment and they made up some [ __ ]
law about they're like yo if you bring
this in you have to pay full sales tax
to us for it and i was like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about and they went
to some oh here he is and yet another
person missing january 13th nothing is
known the famous promoter of monarch
butterflies and mishukhan the corpse of
activist hermano hermano gomez was found
i mean what the [ __ ] is going on there
it's it's terrible
it's terrible it really is the music
yeah the music should probably
not be upbeat at this moment
i mean why it's just why i don't
understand
well you do understand because
that land they want to use it
for growing avocados that's money to
them green goals
it's all about the money
you know you think about like uh those
the most infamous mexican cartels
like uh
chapo or who's the guy before him
but they have so much money you know
it's being eaten by rats they just have
it's like they have so much money they
don't need to kill [ __ ] butterfly
activists just evil
yep there are evil people in this world
that's sad so ripped to a great one eh
yeah it is it's terrible but i'm glad
that the butterflies are
you know are coming back people are
becoming aware of
do you support like a butterfly armed
militia to combat the
an armed militia yeah with milkweed okay
i'm stinking ak or ars
just arm yourselves with milkweed well
someone's got to do something well we
are we're doing something and it's and
you can see that we've made progress
which i think is really exciting yeah
but i was saying the last time we went
there they took the camera equipment and
then they went to some [ __ ] site
where the price is like super inflated
like like let's say it was like three
thousand dollar camera
and they go see on this website it says
five thousand dollars so you owe us like
fifteen percent of that
more the ether they're asking for like
two thousand or i don't know a thousand
dollars cash
yeah they're like they're like we won't
let you in mexico you have to or we're
either going to seize your equipment or
you can't come in
you know when we look down there
there's a much different
tax you pay or don't pay if something's
new versus something that's huge so
when i if you remember i bought a new tv
before he moved down
but i needed it to say on the back it
was made a couple years ago even though
it was new so
anything that's new they tax you what
they determine is the retail price so
has to be all beat up but i'm surprised
since you were just vacationing it's not
like you were going to be living there
and maybe no they started they started
doing that at the airport if they see
something expensive or nice
they'll just shake you down and we had
to pay them a thousand bucks so they
weren't going to let us in mexico and we
we used to go there like all the time
for occasion it was a really fun getaway
yeah and after that we said we're never
coming back here and we haven't well
that was cancun right yeah it was
[ __ ] cancun well there's been all
kinds of shootings there recently too
just last week
someone on a jet ski actually drove by
somewhere and opened fire
drive-by yep that's resort living
i'll tell you what the mexican people
are such beautiful kind-hearted oh yeah
beautiful the country is so beautiful
mexico is such an amazing country and
it's just so it's just so absolutely
tragic
that the criminals are having such a
huge impact down here yeah probably
largely america's fault too to be honest
with you
but we're responsible for all the guns
that the cartels have of course and also
the huge market for drugs that feels
that you know what bad will will wiggle
its way in anywhere
no but that's like
and it and it's up to the governments to
say
no but the governments are just as
corrupt so well the mexican well okay
whatever it's about the government the
mexican government can't do anything
without america uh american backing
because
the guns the money everything's coming
in from america
well
i don't know and who dies
the monarchs yeah my beautiful monarchs
that's why the the cartels have been
against the marijuana legalization
because that's been their big cash crop
in the united states so the more states
that legalize marijuana that actually
really cuts into their profits
keep legalizing everybody
yeah the one really interesting thing i
saw about is that mexico wanted to
legalize all drugs to undercut the
profit motive of the
that would have been a good idea but i
mean
america is ultimately there there
it's where they uh sell their [ __ ] yeah
cash cow well anyway
i have one more thing i want to share
please one more thing
um so in the uk
uh the government has declared lobsters
crabs and octopus
as um
ascentian beings really crabs and
lobsters well you know backbone
animals yeah uh you know the neural
systems are com complex but so are are
the the crabs and the lobsters and the
octopus and so basically like when you
take a lobster or a crab and you throw
it in boiling water
that is abusive
that is really painful for them
they have an advanced uh you know neural
system and and so the uk went ahead and
made them sentient beings
well you know spoil them alive anymore
in the uk i think that they're still
going ahead and fishing the way that
they did but i think that that's a start
to how you approach how to kill an
animal for
your feast for your meal you know like i
mean when cows i mean cows are smart and
they have nervous systems and they don't
just yank their legs off while they're
still alive they don't throw them in
boiling water while they're still alive
so it's a
new way to look at
how to uh
you know kill what you're going to eat
it's it's not human i always thought it
was pretty insane how they throw living
creatures in boiling water like jesus
incredibly inhumane did you ever see
there was a document that won
an award it it it's on netflix it was an
oscar-winning film it's called my my
octopus teacher
did you ever see that
oh my god they're so smart you know i
don't know if you remember you were
awful young do you remember on
burlington when we lived
in that house it was our first house and
and dad and i bought a 45 gallon hexagon
hexagon uh
uh aquarium
and we had all kinds of fish and i would
visit you know the pet store where they
had you know fish and aquatic things all
the time and this guy had a whole set up
it was an a little octopus and he made a
maze and he had a goldfish at the end
and this octopus would climb over open
doors do all kinds of things to get to
the gold fish i knew octopuses were
really smart i think how the crabs and
lobsters were though that surprised me
well i don't know how well they learn
okay they do they learn well shout out
to the um
but another
genius genus name for those the
orthopods or some [ __ ] uh they are
arthropods
cephalopods
[Music]
spiders
although i think they're in the same
genus
i can't believe i didn't write it down
i'm sure i have it written down ah
they're decapods crustacean and
cephalopods shout out to the deca uh
shout out to the
cephalopods of the world we love our
cephalopods folks
yeah
did you know that octopi
um
they're cannibalistic they eat each
other they do kill them [ __ ] them
they don't [ __ ] with cats they do as a
matter of fact when a female lays her
eggs like tens of thousands of eggs and
they uh they painfully string them like
like pearls and then after they do that
mother just mother nature has them
basically starve themselves and so
when they when they are born the mother
pretty much dies because if she didn't
she probably would eat them and when
they mate
when octopi mate sometimes not often but
sometimes uh one of them will eat eat
the other
it's weird because it dies or just
because [ __ ] it we're hungry
they're just just a part of who they
are interesting but um they're really
smart animals i've heard that happens
with humans sometimes too
that they eat eat each other
sorry before or after
it's after sex they do that
yeah i would recommend before if you're
gonna do it
or not maybe you're into that
all right i'm uncomfortable okay um
i was talking about octopus what are you
talking about so let's do i think it's
probably break time and then we'll get
into our fun segment stan
all right so let's throw it to a quick
commercial break and when we come back
it is time for the latka cookoff
[Applause]
thank you to curology
uh you know i love curology it's a face
care product
that customizes a special formula just
for you
through a dermatology provider
you take photos of your skin
you answer a questionnaire
and they formulate a perfect treatment
plan just for you so you don't have to
fritz around at the dermatologist
you know and it's affordable
it's a great system the one that i got
signed up for they sent up a face wash
the uh dermatology provided uh cream
yeah and uh moisturizer
and the the
the cleanse
thank you thank you so much it looks low
no it does but the cleanser is nice and
soft you know it doesn't it doesn't dry
out your skin then you put on the
the cream that they've special
formulated for your skin and then you
moisturize you know moisturizing is is
huge
i love it i've been using it for months
ever since i heard about it and
i think it's great it's great
curology is a game changer and a custom
skincare made for you by a dermatology
provider they'll create a custom
prescription cream for your specific
goals we're talking about acne clogged
pores skin texture dark spots fine lines
or something else you start by taking an
online skin quiz and uploading photos
and if it's a good fit they'll ship you
the formula right to your door
it even has your name on the bottle
so you know
i think it's awesome i really recommend
it uh get started with curology like i
did with a free 30-day trial at
curology.com h3 pay just five dollars
for shipping and handling
that's
c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com slash h3 and
start your free 30-day trial you can
cancel any time
prescription is subject to consultation
so thank you thank you curology
i
love hbo max and dad i'm pretty sure you
can back me up on this isn't like the
best streaming service yeah we like i am
obsessed with hbo max
uh they have kept me stocked up and
streaming the best stuff and it's not
even all the good stuff you expect they
have like networks
uh they call it like hubs i think you
have access to all this other cool stuff
um yeah like turner classic movies yeah
i love that i mean every great old movie
is on there there's so many things it's
amazing and then you also get this thing
uh crunchyroll which is an anime
provider which i'm into and i've watched
a lot of the great new animes that i
wouldn't be able to watch anywhere else
i know you're into anime right dad oh
absolutely yeah
yeah i got the tenor classics i got the
anime
but you know here's some titles that you
are going to be able to watch on hbo max
dune
yeah
you know i've read like two and a half
of the whole books now after watching
that oh really yeah i'm on the third
book wait a minute there's three books
of doom there's like seven
um
dune okay
dune i read dune when i was like 16
years old
but i didn't realize there were seven
books
there's a bunch of them oh that's
interesting yeah so dune the many saints
of newark which is the prequel to um
sopranos succession season three and
secure season five curb season 11. you
know what else is coming out this month
the matrix oh i want to see that it's
coming out on this field
i'm freaking pumped for that bro i i'm
really excited i gotta say that's uh
it's one of the i think it's the most
exciting event about a film in a long
time yeah and that's all on hbo max you
guys hvl max has all your favorite
titles available for streaming and they
got something for everyone with
everything you love all in one place
plus you can download top titles to
watch on your devices to go don't miss
out
on taking your entertainment game to the
next level hbo max is the streaming home
of over 13 000 hours of addictive series
blockbuster movies and exclusive
originals start streaming on your
favorite device today sign up at hbom
dot ax
slash
h3
ra what the [ __ ] is this url slash h3
rails dec are you freaking just go to
the link in the description
that's a hell of a url i'm going to read
it one more time
hbom
dot ax
slash h3 rails dec what in god's earth
is that
they could streamline that well
if you can get to the url
you're going to love hbo masks
so thank you i do love hbo max so much
so thank you to being sponsored for them
and god bless
yeah really i love hbo max two all right
after blowing out the power of the whole
office
and having to run one to the far end and
one to the other far end of the studio
we're back
these things are power hogs okay um
but we're here
and oh there was one thing i wanted a
story i wanted you to tell because dan
was here helping us get set up and
you're staring at him and i was like i
was looking at the back of his neck i'm
hair stylist sure of course and you're
staring at him i was like mom what are
you staring at dan so intently for that
you were admiring his expertise or
something no and what what were you
staring because you know he obviously
shaves
all of his his hair off on his on his
head yeah and i know that dan
has a little bit of of um
like a bald spot a little bit of ball
you have a little bit of a ball i call
it the yamaka spot
the yamaka spot is where you have it and
i was you know i'm always on the phone
looking at different things and i saw
this one because i i always look at
tutorials for pictures i mean for for
haircuts and things like that and there
was this tattoo
uh
place
and they did little tiny dots
in spots where men
had balding spots and it looked so real
so you so i sent a message to dan and i
thought does this bother you and if it
does this might did she say that or did
she say oh she said tell me what she
actually said to you dan i mean i could
pull it up yeah pull it up let's get the
receipts and you could so my mom reaches
out to dan well i yeah and she says hey
hey you called [ __ ] no i didn't hey you
bald
[ __ ] i know my family comes from
hairline king
you have good stock my family is uh the
pedigree we would never need any of this
[ __ ]
but you may need this well because he
always wears a hat so i thought maybe he
was trying to you know guys that have
hairline received
they like wearing a hat it looks good
it's insecure yeah i just you know i
mean you don't see aby wearing a a a hat
back so i thought i wear a hat
you do but you i i think because your
wife is a designer and she's got these
awesome hats that you enjoy keemstar
wears a hat
right he's not totally throwing that out
there is he is he bald no
has anyone ever seen him without the hat
he's as bald as a boiled chicken
is he
interested did you like that enough he
makes dan look like me that's how bald
he is all right dan you got that
he said he makes dan look like him the
message said hey dan i just saw a video
where a guy was having little dots on
his head to mimic hair follicles that
have been shaved when
down the guy just looked like he shaved
his head and wasn't bald at all it
looked amazing just thought i'd share
that with you i look to see if i can
find it again
that was the whole mess amazing well i
was just thinking about him i saw that
and i thought well it was her dance very
sweet that you're thinking of it i don't
know i thought you went insulted
it was not insulting i just found it
hilarious i immediately shared it with
the rest of the crew i was like uh so
donna just reached out and sent me this
video
so what was your initial reaction to
that just like i mean
i laughed yeah i mean it's [ __ ]
hilarious
if you notice any insecurities of anyone
else around the house if you just want
to point those out
not that you're insecure dan i know
you're a bald king at this point at this
point i've fully accepted it i've
embraced it i've had enough people um
lie to me and say that it looks good
yeah you convinced well you know what i
have to tell you some men look better
bald than others in fact some men look
better bald than having hair like that
kid not a kid rock uh rock the big hulky
guy the raw rock the rock it's about
fruit
and i like it better with that i get
that all the time that i look just like
the rock i appreciate you pointing that
out
all right bring out the vodkas
oh you do so okay so here's the deal
we've pre-prepped our mix because it's a
tedious thing basically my my pan is
starting to smoke which i think is
probably bad because there's no oil in
it no we wanted to heat the pan up
this is
wait do we have oh mine is right here
okay good okay we're missing we're
missing a fourth of a cup
all right well use your imagination i'll
just use a half so so um let me pour
this in
basically we pre-prepped
our mixture
we'll talk about that but i want to get
it on the pan because mine's smoking and
you don't want to dry smoke there you go
i think that means it's like teflon
cancer doesn't it no i don't think so
i don't think i'll ever be able to give
birth again after this
well avocado oil has a real high burn
point too
this is a big pan
yeah come on you don't want to be shy
about it you guys are using avocado oil
yes it's the high is that a good is that
what your request was yeah because
avocado can burn at a high temperature
where olive oil will burn
so i didn't know that you supported the
cartels
you know california puts out a lot of
avocados
how do you know look on there where's
that from little stamp says santa paula
okay thank god all right there'd be
butterfly death on your hands try and
lean down to the mic when you're talking
oh okay
yes so
this is my own recipe
versus my mom's recipe
you have a way to keep it separate so
people know whose is who's
well yeah we're going to do a
we're going to do a blind test i mean
you have a plate yeah we need our i need
my own plate here i only have one plate
here for pl fur
for plating
so basically you want to talk about your
preparation uh process there well since
you've already done yours i don't have
to worry about
you mimicking me yeah okay so if you
have a
if you have um
potatoes
if say you have six potatoes what you
want first of all the ingredients that
you need
are matzo meal potatoes onions you want
a little bit of uh
if you don't have potato starch you can
use cornstarch
and you want an egg
you or you need eggs just yeah what's
your process and salt and pepper and so
what you do is
you have the choice of grating your
potatoes or in my case what i love is um
i don't like them shredded i like them
so that they're
completely
grated smooth so you grate them you dry
them you mix it with egg and flour
mozzarella all that right but the most
important thing about potato pancakes
making a really good potato pancake is
making sure
that they are
rinsed and what i do you got to rinse
the starch out what i do is right is
that what you mean yeah you can use you
can use a cheese cloth
or what i do is i have one of those
strainers you know like what you put
noodles in yep and i actually have the
water run over it you have to have a
real fine screen though and then you
just kind of get all the moisture out
and then what you do is you grate up
your onion and you put it into the mix
next what i do is i gotta make mine
smaller because i'm just cooking i use
matzo meal you can use flour matzo meal
has a really sweet flavor and if you
don't have matzo meal you can use panko
bread crumbs
and that works just as good you know for
substitute and then you want to use a
little bit of cornstarch
and um
and
that and salt and pepper
and that's pretty much so basically i
got in the matrix here because i said i
will not let my mom defeat me i had your
lockers this week and i was like they're
pretty good you know
so i went into the lab oh they were
pretty good
they're pretty good what do you want
that's that's good what do you want me
to say they're [ __ ] busting yeah
yeah they weren't busting they were
pretty good okay
how come my oh my god
my frying pan is not getting hot maybe
you can turn up the heat yeah maybe
mine's not hot enough either eh oh you
do i have mine on max well maybe because
my pan's bigger than yours i'm going up
to max too
so anyway i went to the laboratory i did
lots of research so here was my process
was first i boiled the potato
you boiled pre-cooked
okay i've never done that and then
basically i that'll make it nice and
fluffy i think exactly so i pref i pre i
uh boiled it and then i
um
shredded it you you grated it i uh
i blend yeah i just blended it up with
all the ingredients you didn't you
didn't you didn't drain it
no i did i dried it off okay and then i
blended it oh god i'm careful because
i'm afraid it's gonna splash here you
know what you do give me okay you're
going to splash oil on me i know you are
no don't touch that it's so hot don't do
it no no no
no you cut my block in half sabotage
i didn't want you to do it i said don't
do it and then you're doing that and
then i trusted you and you
obliterated it that's because you didn't
let go if you let go well why do you
think i didn't let go because i didn't
want you to do it
you just locked you just
locker violated me
put another one in there you only have
one yeah i got it how come mine is not
getting hot
it's hot what do you want god it's not
getting hot
boiling i don't it's not hot well anyway
so i put them all in the blender
right
and um these are not hot
and then i put them over in the fridge
overnight
and that's what you see here a really
beautiful creamy
um
potatoey i noticed yours is brown mine
is like beautiful look how creamy and
beautiful that is you know what when it
when potatoes oxidize
yeah well i keep mine on i keep mine
away from the oxygen
and you know what if you shred
um your potatoes yukon potatoes are
always better than a russet i like the
gravy like the yukons
yukons are really good when you when you
shred them but when you enter but i like
the russets when you when you grate them
because it's a thicker potato when you
put it through this so is is uh laca
cooking a tradition in your family mom
was was grandma was your mom good at uh
at lacaze is this a legacy or did you
get your recipe online
no my mother used to my mom my mom made
really good potato lockies my mother was
a terrible cook but when it came to
holiday meals she was the queen she was
really good at it
oh really yeah she was she was good at
holiday meals yeah i mean mine's not
that i mean it's cooking really slow do
they usually take this long to cook uh
yeah if you want to yeah they do that's
why i said we need to prepare
that's true all the time because yes so
i mean the yeah the preparation takes a
long time takes a long time
and these these are cook and so flipping
slow
i guess it ain't the same as just having
of the old fire uh
underneath of me i may be i don't i
don't know mine are looking here i'm
gonna see if i can flip this so look at
the look at the difference you got like
oozy bro like sewage
black
and mine are beautiful fresh like look
at that oh my god luscious please look
at that marsh fluffy marshmallows of
heaven oh my god nothing to worry about
nuts have him
that's heaven
i wish i could taste it
a little hot
ethan's pan looks hotter
thank you because it's smaller that's
what i said well i have more oil i have
more oil but it's a smaller surface so
the heat
i think i have more oil
i don't think my dad should judge i
don't think we switch pans
you want my pan
you want my pan
look at all the oil look at all this
beautiful seasoning i've done mine's
look at how it's more bubbling put more
oil no it doesn't need any more it's
frying yours is like sad [ __ ] dude no
it's just not getting hot enough oh my
god the excuses they coming already
no as
as
the public can easily see there's more
boiling going on in this one but i have
way more oil because i'm a i'm a little
it's a smaller pan what
gary
gary dan what dad can you just stand
right in front of all the cameras please
yeah my dad is the main character why
don't you stand next to my mom
yeah stand now but you've got to talk
into her mic okay she can hit me
they can't hear you unless you talk into
the mic in fact why don't you sit here
you're always at the children's team i
don't feel right being here
okay our mom my mom's got those real
skills she's putting her fingers in the
burning oil that's mom [ __ ] do you know
i don't really have much of a a
fingerprint look at those all of those
fingernails
yeah your finger your nails are all the
years of doing bleach and stuff
you know
you think you'd be unidentified you
think you could evade the fbi no
no
that's my fingerprints my fingerprints
what did i say
you think you lost sensation in your
fingertips like you could burn them and
it wouldn't hurt as much
uh
no oh my god look at these bro you're
gonna lose oh geez
sure you got the small hot paint in
there
look at they're like little s they're
like little scallops bro you have
yourself no the truth is i use more oil
you don't use enough oil that's telling
you it's the same amount of oil i put
way more oil mine is like halfway up the
pan my mom like measured out carefully
one tiny thing i was like let's go uh
mexican cartel
no
you just you just um
have
a hotter pan
i have five here is that enough i have
we can cut them in half too okay good i
have five
all right this is five this is really
exciting
actually i want to make the rest because
i want it mine is so good i want more i
would say that's busting where yours are
pretty good keep going keep going keep
going i'm adding keep going you look
you've got to cover the whole pan ethan
more okay you're good i'm telling you
it's the size of the pan
and well they say it ain't the size of
the pan
it's the motion of the spatula besides
it's not this is not hot enough
move gary
gary get the hell out of the way
there's the kind of treatment i'm used
to yeah well you're just you're in the
way you're in the way move it get the
hell out of the way okay story of my
life oh stop
oh [ __ ]
that's what the [ __ ] is up i'm making a
biggest vlog
i can't believe you boiled them well i
have i told you
i transcend
you're in the traditions you're like in
the old ways you're in the stone age i'm
in the future
this is the future of vladka making all
right mom's cooking them the way moses
did
yeah back in the day yeah with prayer
with prayer not recent moses the moses
from the bible just want to make that
clear
i think it was clear what the you didn't
need the clairvoyant all right yeah
all right all right
all right so let's do like basically i
think there needs to be three categories
here on
on appearance on texture on flavor okay
well appearance years it probably wins i
think
thank you so much for saying that
but flavor i'm hoping
yeah maybe you guys can there's one big
one you guys can cut in half as well all
right so i'm gonna go for donna's first
okay i can't see you but they can right
right yeah
i think mine probably tastes more
traditional talk about appearance talk
about appearance
it's a little bit more brown than i'm
used to looking alive but i gotta say
it uh is pretty similar to the way my
family
cooks it
um texture's good
nothing further father um well crispy
exterior nice and soft on the inside
um pretty solid pretty solid donna thank
you
okay i'm gonna try ethan
ethan's is closer to the color than i'm
used to i will say
um it's a little bit fatter it looks
more like a a tater tot than a lock from
being [ __ ]
it does come off
yeah ethan's tastes a little more like a
tater tot or a hash brown
versus a lot key
in my opinion another woman i have to go
home with well we mean you didn't ask i
didn't ask him yet oh okay
no i've never had these prior that's the
first time
okay
the one i got of ethan's is a little bit
burnt but i gotta say ethan's
with peace and love donna tastes better
thank you okay
a.b
and he ain't just simping
simple ain't easy but it's necessary
yeah i'll say again i think donna's is
more on the money for for what i would
consider a traditional latka
um ethan's
i i'm leaning ethan thank you dan oh man
dan's a hater dan is looking for any
reason to undermine me
i i tried both
uh like everyone else said donna yours
reminds me of how my grandmother makes
them yep
which we love which we love i gotta go
ethan i'm sorry thank you
like i tried mine and i was like this is
the best luck i've ever had
it's [ __ ] bombed it is
what is that that's a gigantic i'm
making one big one who else is trying
one sam olivia everyone get in here now
come on oh my god i just tried them
uh
don't be and ian don't spare my mom
she's a big girl i don't want none of
this oh i voted for her because i felt
bad you know maybe i just got a bit
unlucky here
but
the one i got from you ethan is
pretty singed well you're not supposed
to eat the burn side most of it is burnt
okay so whatever i'll take an l i'm
gonna have to go don on this one
whatever yeah all right one for donna
i got one i'm going with donna too since
this was a
potato lotki
not a
potato hash brown competition so ethan's
were good nice and fluffy i think
boiling the potatoes definitely made a
difference in texture but maybe if they
had been a little bit thinner the
thinness huh but i'm i'm going with your
mother yeah i knew my dad would never go
against you oops
i think it's three to two right
uh it is um
is it two to two it is three to two a b
you you voted for ethan's as well right
yeah i knew that my dad would never go
against that's like asking moses to vote
against trisha like it will never happen
olivia's got to vote here come on come
on
okay
so
are you familiar with i am familiar with
the vodka yeah
um
ethan the one i got from you is raw in
the middle so oh what are you talking
about i'm gonna have to go with dawn on
this one what are you talking about
bring that here we got a tie
we are tied up we're tied up
you can't let me see she's saying it's
well yours look like well there's no
mulligans ethan
how is this raw
isn't it
of course not how dare you
okay well she's still like is it any
better if it just tastes wrong
that's the raw one
okay well whatever she likes my better
look at the inside
talk to the hand olivia that's why abe
likes it i'm sorry she's given her final
answer there's no changing your votes
all right here i hear some more potatoes
so we have sam
who's left
sam
yeah here comes sam sam and cam
so now it's tied somehow
all right i gotta say
i gotta go down on this one oh my god
based on what
based on what
taste the taste
there's just more flavorful i don't know
oh my gosh and i love the the texture i
thought was a lot better too oh my god
i love hash browns well that that hurts
that hurts more because sam is like the
chef and that just hurts sam you know
you went against the family today and it
hurts oh what do you mean you can't do
that ethan you have to do it did you
guys use the same seasoning i'm curious
as to i did salt and pepper and that's
it that's you keep it real salt and
pepper
did you add onions
oh well this i'm not feeding them this
i um
i'm gonna have to make one master one
first cam
do you have onions in there ethan yeah
i've onions i have an egg
i have corn starch and i have matzo meal
salt and pepper i think it's basically
the same ingredients just a different
preparation technique where mine's a
little more high level you would say
high level mine's more kind of like
gastronomy what do they call it when
they use the science with food
gastronomy yeah it's mine is more
inspired by gastronomy mom
oh how is it gastronomy just because you
boiled the potatoes yeah
it's kind of high level you have to go
to culinary school to come please or
what i'm doing can you pass the avocado
sauce i have to make one master log cup
for cam and then who said theirs was
burned ian
and then and then um olivia said hers
was overcooked so i'm going to make
three
i want you guys so is it
hers
olivia said hers was undercooked yeah so
i'm going to make three more and i want
to re-judge
that the mulligan you said no mulligans
i'm changing the rules oh my god pray i
don't change them any further
maybe we should go out front and do a
man on the street
taste test yeah homeless people oh ask
the guy that that does the parking swap
yeah
ask the guy that does the parking i'm
making two right now that's a good idea
let's do that actually ran out of mitts
let me see if i have no you use that
swami will say the swami will pick the
third option all right so i'm making
four more i want to i want to retest
from
olivia sam
and ian
and i want swami in on this too ladies
and gentlemen swami the legend
all right so swami is our security guard
have you ever had a uh
have you ever had a potato latke in your
life what's this
this new item he can he could you could
talk into the microphone okay
have you ever eaten one of these i think
this is different new yeah okay it's a
new dish for swami swami where are you
from by the way uh from bangladesh so
swami is from bangladesh he's here
because he's a
he's a um
a yogi master right you're here on some
kind of yeah he's here on a visa because
he's he does
like real yoga that's why
yeah
he's not like these fake ass hippie your
mistake he's like a real young mistake
all right swami
one one is my mom's and one is mine you
tell it tell us which one you like
better
i think this one better you gotta taste
it
wait he didn't taste it
the look is nice of one of them
okay we like that
we like the we like that
are you a fan of potato swami let him
eat
my potatoes are ice cold dude they were
hot first
stop telling them whose is who
gary so i can test right
i can't believe your father just said
that
we can't tell you
i'll tell you we have to wait till you
try both of them then we'll tell you
who's who's you got to decide which
one's better whatever you tasted you
like so i need to check both yeah
so that's option one
so i already did one he did one now
let's try that one so
let's put it in the freezer
how's it going
that's your final answer first one's
better yeah first one is better which is
ethan's
[Applause]
you made the right yeah you made the
right choice thank you swami thank you
swami i think that makes it a tie ethan
not in your face so much nope because
thank you swam we love you so much
namaste to you my friend thank you thank
you all of you thank you i love you all
we love you swami fam swami family
family family
wow swamy
well you know what ethan it just really
wasn't fair my my pan was was um what
the hell called block was cold cold
wait
being warm and being right off the
frying pan is not the same yeah i'm
coming to the microphone now
come here sam it's hot it's hot
come on go ahead
the latke was
hot
it wasn't piping hot like ethan's but it
was it was it was very hot it was very
hot
okay but here's the thank you sam and
i'm sorry to put you in the middle of
this family drama
ian complained about burn
olivia complained about under cooking
now guys come get a taste of this
come on now get back in here
now he did eat it with a knife and fork
which is very untraditional that may
have changed the flavor i believe he's
he's an untraditional guy so yeah here
we are that's [ __ ] good right you see
dan dancing over here
how good is that [ __ ] let me get some of
that love dan
come on so let me try it actually
oh cam what cam never voted
grab
mine or ice cold i want to grab whatever
you want be honest about the the
temperature of mine
okay take a picture well even now it's
still hot no it's not hot it's hot yeah
even now it's hot
no i can't eat it she can't even eat it
i can't even feel it
yeah feel it it's still hot like
i feel like you could i don't want you
you won't even feel it now i see how it
is
so did you did your
vote change
no i still vote for you okay
you can't vote it for me
can't vote it for me that's the dub
it was very close margin okay well
i have a i have a confession to make
what's that
i won by one vote
right yeah
what's your confession
i use the
manifesto oh are you kidding me
build your mic use your mic
you used a box i didn't do anything i
just used manish oh lord no wonder your
potatoes were
were light
mine has been sitting in the
refrigerator
nobody forced you to do that
well because i wanted to save time
all i did here is you take the powder do
you see what he did gary
the judges have disqualified ethan
all i did was put in two eggs
two cups of water
and a little bit of vegetable oil and
mix it up
and that's a dub right there oh my god
i think he went on technicality though
i just i didn't expect to actually take
the dub though
i heard these were very good i heard
these were very well listen they are
when you make matzo ball soups i get i
get the mixed packages
they
they have it down to a science well you
know what gave me the idea to do this
talk to my friend isaac
and he goes
i'm going to stop my tune
and he goes uh he was trying when he
moved out with him he had his own family
he's trying and trying to try to make
the potato latkes like he remembers his
mom made right he's like they're never
as good as my mom made right so one day
i went home for hanukkah i said mom
what's your recipe because i keep trying
it it's never as good she said oh i just
use the mana chevits
so you don't boil a potato no of course
not
because you were saying boiling a potato
i'm going to have i had to sell it
wrong i had to sell it oh my god that
was a clever lie ethan thank you so much
well
you stinker i think you take the default
w
well done all right against man of
shadows
i mean
a billion dollar company thousands of
years of heritage
how can you stand against mannishevic's
empire there you have it get manish of
its uh premium it is very good
no but you can't replace the uh the love
you can't replace the love the love do
you feel bad that i beat you with the
manage of it no i feel better yeah i
thought you would feel better that i
didn't actually cook it i'm like oh my
god how did i lose that yeah no you you
get the dub oh my god there's no
replacing cooking at yourself how much
was this was this i mean 99 cents
and how many oh seven seven so because
when i cook
i make a lot of potato potato pancakes i
mean how many packs were in this this
says it provides one 18 to 14. one pack
that shit's like 99 cents this is it
provides 18 to 14 potatoes they must be
like this dollar size i don't know i
mean how many did you make altogether
i have no idea not that much i have no
idea about anything all right i do i
didn't even mix the batter sam did that
oh i just scooped it down
little stinker it was funny though come
on give us a break all right
all right well moving on moving on
now is the portion this is interesting
this thing
it doesn't seem very good i'll tell you
why besides blowing the entire
street's power out
i can smell the burning plastic on the
handle
ooh and
it got so hot
that the dial to turn on and off is like
so [ __ ] hot i can't even touch it
i don't think my god yeah i guess it is
hot how much were these things we just
got them for the show
oh my god that explains that's why 30
bucks but it says oh cuis and max i
thought i was going to say cuisinart
it's that off brown cuisinart yeah
i mean it worked
okay so anyway this has got gonna be hot
we gotta let this all this so up next
guys
is the boomer test
that is going to rock the gaming world
oh my mom versus my dad
gamer edition and by just a reminder the
winner gets a
massive gift
so you are not going to want to lose
this head head-to-head
massive gift
and i'm not just talking about my body
it's like a hug for me
a new car
no more like a a bale full of hay or
it might be a new car you know
you know pretty i'm like pretty generous
around the christmas time
uh uh
i can't even think what it could be okay
i'm not gonna want to lose
so let's cut and we're gonna go to halo
mom vs dad one on one okay no video game
experience by the way i have none yeah
dad you've played video games i've
played bong no dead pong i don't think
you've ever used one of those
controllers oh you played bong yeah that
probably was the last video is that what
you said you played bomb he said
pog
nothing in the last
10 15 years or so so
we're on the same footing pretty much
all right let's cut and we'll get to the
death match okay let's do it okay guys
so here we are in halo
we have a 1v1 death match first to five
kills
neither of you guys have played
video games let alone first person
shooter are used what we have here is
ps5 controllers
okay
and can we display their names um
like on the blue team we have
dad's the blue team i'm the yellow
so my dad is team skeet 420
and which color is he
blue he's always blue
because i'm okay and then my mom is the
xxx don arc xxx on the red team no i'm
on the yellow aren't they
oh i'm a red team my guy's just yellow
yeah okay yeah
okay so here we go okay i'll be coaching
my mom
and then av is going to be coaching my
dad
all right let the games begin so
all right the the right button is shoot
you see the trigger whoa
okay so i have whoa so if i want to try
to hit a target so one of these is whoa
this is really hard to maneuver okay so
one of those is going to turn left and
right and one of them go forward so try
using both at the same time
you see that's forward
did i get it
that's nothing oh you're just going to
shoot at that if you see another player
that's who you want to shoot okay and
then if you want to reload push the
square how do i know if i'm out just
push square yeah okay so oh that's kind
of cool okay so now practice moving
around and turning turn to your right
okay good okay a little less
so
okay good so now try just try walking
forward
oops wait ah
yeah oh i think i see dad where where
right there right there he's right there
he's shooting at you wait no calm down
calm down just gather yourself he sucks
too push square just the right push
square oh [ __ ] he's gone
so he's some he's to your left he's to
your left look slowly just calmly he
sucks still yeah yeah yeah yeah get
right get their crosshair right on them
and just unload wow they're not hitting
each other they're staring at each other
but they're not hitting
there you go there you go
yeah okay calm down
just remember right these things are
soft
all right so you might want to go closer
to him
just go back go back go back i don't
think dad hit you once go down you want
to aim down because there's recoil now
bounces up okay he's coming at you he's
coming at you no don't shoot he's not
you don't shoot at nothing go up go up
go up go up go up aim up i'm trying he's
like
just unleash unleash don't move unleash
[Music]
w
you're like a star trooper dude that was
awesome
a star trek that was good thank you all
right four more dubs now how do i know
when i'm out of ammunition don't worry
about that all right push x though to
reload i mean not ex square square
i'm pushing oh [ __ ] you might be out of
bullets
nope i got it i only have five bullets
left you're gonna have to go walk around
i hear him i hear him
where is he
wait turn to your left turn to your left
he's turn to your left
left turn around for christ's sake i am
turning not boy's so slow oh you told me
not to go fast well not that slow damn
all right you can move around go walk
around you got to go get a new weapon
because you only have five bullets left
there he is you only have five bullets
man
all right you're out so push why push y
y or no push up i thought it was square
wait what is y why are they saying why
because it's thinking it's an x box so
which button is why
it'd be the top one
push triangle push triangle
okay now you got a pistol go [ __ ] him up
just to be calm
oh my god this is the best showdown ever
you got go right there down um no a
little bit to the left little touch to
the left
down a little bit a little now unload
unload
unload unload no don't jump i didn't it
jumps by itself right it jump download
unload you keep going keep going keep
shooting i'm trying no aim up line it up
line it up line it up you got to go up
you're shooting between his legs up up
up up up up
oh [ __ ] mom
oh
look right there just unload don't move
unlock oh [ __ ]
oh my god my dad can't hit [ __ ] oh lord
neither can i oh [ __ ] a what
what what happened there a melee attack
wait dude what was that maybe might have
pressed a little i showed him where to
push i showed him where to push hold the
phone wait everybody control us down
a b
i showed him where to push
ian did you see him push something
i'd have to see the instant reaper i'm
looking and
you're back alive it's 1-1 now
okay all right so now i'm i'm back with
my machine gun
you're both using controllers right
right so go walk start walking around a
little bit
try to find him you know
because he keeps coming to you i mean
come on now you gotta i don't know where
so use your there you go that's good
turn left
okay
you're just
okay you've got to kind of want to look
where you're going a little bit turn
your if you're walking you want to look
where you're walking right because he
might be left to you he's not gary where
are you in a dead end turn around
turn around keep going okay now walk
this way straight
wait
oh i have to go this way yeah go that
way
so you're getting better at it oh man is
you know what the the the uh
everything's so sensitive keep going
straight
oh look it's a whole world
what do you mean i mean like you can go
to different places yeah
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i hear him i hear him
you might want to you might want to move
because he might be behind you and he'll
melee you again
[ __ ]
i hear him scuffling around i hear him
you don't necessarily want to stand
still because he'll just bop you
where is he
what the heck oh my god
where is he
well he's not here oops
all right yeah that's good turn left
slow nice and easy put your aimer down
he's not gonna you want to put your
aimer where he's gonna be right he's
gonna be like down a little bit more
down more yeah he's gonna be like
a little higher than that
why won't he go forward oh there we go i
think you were hitting up on something
what is this hold on this is a item you
might want to pick up what does that
mean what do i do walk up to it
no don't shoot it walk up on it
walk up on it
okay that's that's what is that i think
it's a grenade or something oh oh
oh slowly turn slowly
okay
just just unload unload put it down put
it down
unload
it
you got it
move forward i'm pushing both
move forward the joystick the joystick
no you're looking up go forward
go forward
okay good now look down
look down
look down
turn around turn around turn around
turn around
look the other way
okay there he is there he is
you've got to aim him before you shoot
just use the left stick just use a
little just now shoot unload i'm pushing
this push-up
push push push
dude this melee [ __ ] this thing is
really hard to make a favor yeah
oh so [ __ ] comfortable
okay hold on how do you melee
how do i melee you can't steal our
strategy it's uh right stick you gotta
click it okay click this down
that's what dad's choosing maybe he's
doing some cheesy [ __ ] with dad
where he just appreciates we we've given
up on shooting push [ __ ] you see how
it's it you strike them with your weapon
so that's what their [ __ ] strategy
is right now okay well here let's oops
blowing things up
where is he i don't hear him
uh i hear him
oh down there she's down go straight
perfect perfect keep going
look left
straight it sounds like a door opening
oh
how can you jump over here
up yeah up there
right there oh there he is
[Music]
okay
let's do this again that one didn't
count obviously
that was me oh that was you yeah that
was me and you accused me i was just
doing a goofy team honesty over here
i was up front about it
wait i think they see you because i hear
you'd be sitting right there oh my god
you just threw a grenade on yourself
i did
yes you did i think that go turn left
turn left go right up to that thing on
the wall turn left left left left
okay right there i see that thing on the
wall glowing go right up to that
that blue glow god dang look down oh my
god
my god mom what was that i think it's an
innate
thing that men know how to do this dad
was literally sitting there shooting at
[ __ ]
like what is this blue thing on top okay
hold on you gotta look down you got
that's your shield don't worry about it
oh look up okay you're you're unlearning
everything i've taught you you're just
staring at the ground now okay okay get
to your get your aiming position right
in the middle
aiming position right in the middle
right there okay now let's look for him
okay now don't panic
don't panic remember the controls
okay
remember there he is there he is
what don't don't shoot until you're
aiming at him
right there unload
you got him that was all my mom
that was a that was good i did a melee
attack i did she threw a grenade too
that was insane
i alright wait what's the legit score
right now
i think it's one to one
oh three two
yep my mom only got three okay three
three
if you're including my cheating kill
no
okay reload push push square
okay now remember your training mom
remember your training get in the
position wait what are you doing
i'm not i got it get in your position
okay now turn turn
turn
go down aim down see you're aiming too
high right you gotta aim where he's
gonna be right there okay okay no i
okay just be aware you're surrounded
what is this thing in front of me don't
worry let me it's just a thing you can
pick up don't worry about it it's not a
big deal do you wear your surroundings
i hear him try turning around he might
be behind you
you you got to be aware of your
surroundings look up
okay
you want to jump push x
but push forward
[ __ ] he's i think he's behind you
you better look behind you
okay no he's not
[ __ ]
okay look to your left look to your left
look to your left
look up you got to look up
keep your keep your cursor in the middle
he's he's real close to you mom i think
he's behind you
oh my god he's behind you just run get
out of there get out of there run move
don't look up to the sky remember you're
training
remember you're trying to look down why
won't it move no no no you're you're
getting it
this goes down that goes down to aim now
run no
aim up look up oh [ __ ] turn right look
up look up now move just run get out of
there you're in the corner you're
running into a corner stop aiming up
look down just left stick look down look
down now just run now get the [ __ ] he's
right there just destroy his ass unload
on him
he's he's stuck
right there move aim down left stick
just move left yep yep right there go
upstairs
he's coming to get you just look at your
feet and run
okay all right just relax re re-center
how can i relax you're yelling at me
okay no no no don't shoot until he's
right there don't shoot until you have
them stand up okay up a little turn turn
left to your right to your right to your
right to your right good job left left
flip
look right he's right there on your
right right right right right right
right right right there right there yep
oh my god move he's got you aimed up you
better you've not aimed me just go up
you're right yeah i'm shooting just walk
but don't don't shoot until he's in your
crosstalk straight yep what are you
shooting at now
press it yep
okay good job just back up and let your
shield recharge shoot her just let your
okay get out get out he's trying to
melee you just run away from it turn
right run away good job great job mom
jump push x push x
and push x and four great job okay now
push reload push square to reload okay
now turn around because you know he's
right behind you turn around you got
lots of ammo no no left left right stick
i'm sorry right stick yeah right there
you want to look down that corridor go
straight okay now just
good job
look left just wait
i think i think she's over there
yep
just don't panic when you see him right
the winner is the cool one don't shoot
until he's in your crosshair
don't panic just be calm
get him in that cross here and on
[ __ ] load on it i'm trying
hold x
move move move move move nevermind it's
not complicated okay go to the left
let's see let's look around a little bit
see if we can spot him
[Music]
so go straight and you're gonna want to
turn to the right jesus just don't panic
keep it cool go straight
i got it go straight this is this one i
know i know i know okay so look right
look right
look right
look right
okay quicker
quicker
there he is there he is he's right
[ __ ] there just go and look he's
trying to melee you back up back it up
get out of there he's trying to melee
you get out of there i'm trying i can't
move
i'm moving this thing and it won't it
won't move you keep moving
gary you keep pushing the wrong button
you're you're pushing the look
now just remember do the move isn't this
the move yes well i keep on doing it
looking up in the air when you panic you
look in the air oh lord this goes up
this goes down this goes right right
forward remember you don't have to just
move forward if you're in a corner you
can't walk the wall now i'm trying to
make it go right because there's a wall
to your right so how do i have to walk
forward you see you're trying to run
into a wall walk forward
by the way get that
on the wall you see that thing pick that
up it's extra ammo
get that
just walk
forward oh it's a different gun
nevermind don't do that
okay gary is uh one kill away from
winning by the way
just all the best advice i can give you
is don't panic i've been so paranoid
that that first kill i possibly hit the
button
but either way where is he it's equal
now
okay you're looking at a wall so you you
don't want to be looking at the wall
you won't be looking at open spaces
okay turn to the right
look to the right you think he could be
in there
no
definitely not look to the right
look to the right see why aren't you
looking to the right
okay good
okay
can we get an instant replay of abe
touching
my dad i really don't know if i did but
either way it would be the same score
because you did it once again no but
well i know we removed it
i'm just overthinking it now wait i'm
jumping and you have to push forward
also
jumping forward x okay good
okay so it's not oh there we go all
right now look up
center your aim
center your aim up up up okay now we
want to look around look to your right
remember the two different
i hear him yeah i hear him
this is high level this is really making
me nervous yeah this is the most
nerve-wracking game i've ever seen this
is high level
high level gaming
all right look to the left look around
look around look at your surroundings
there you go oh there okay i remember
don't shoot he's gonna he's just gonna
mail you you gotta back up there unleash
unleash oh did i get to the right yeah
he's almost dead
oh my gosh yes the melees
oh
i just can't maneuver these all right
now me versus uav oh god well that's not
you
yeah one round oh it's over it's over
oh you won that was painful it was
really painful this makes me nervous
things are so sensitive yeah yeah good
job good try all right so my dad took
the dub
thank you mom got two kills which is
impressive i mean mom did get two kills
i've never done this before coach you
got a good you got a good shooting shot
you got a good melee kill
a dad in the end he had the uh killed me
those six four times gun butts
that was like suicide bomber just blow
everything up right how do you guys feel
you guys ready to pick up video gaming i
think that was fun yeah what what what
game i think you guys will have a really
good chance against the people online i
want to get this this game i'd love to
see you try to play on online do it for
money
no i i like there's pro leagues i think
it'd be fun to play against each other
dude i would love if you guys became
yeah
you have to hook up to the tv can we do
that in the family room it's all online
oh so we don't have to stick wires in
anywhere no okay good technology baby
all right well dad i promised an epic
gift so av you want to run this over
from your sure looks smaller than a
breadboard thank you why do you keep
saying bread because you said it was big
oh
a bread box is what you think of when
you think big well no you know i was
just
saying thank you thank you you said it
was big so i
thought it was something large
so should i open this yeah open it of
course
two gift cards to ruth chris steakhouse
oh the corner from our house yes
do you think wallace can stay home by
himself another couple hours so he can
go eat no but we'll go another day oh
thank you very much ethan yes so those
are i don't know if they look familiar
to you but those are the you guys gave
me two ruth chris gift cards for my
birthday last year oh you're re-gifting
so the winner
what the hell enjoy
nice steak dinner so all right
congratulations
i actually they were just sitting on my
you guys gave them for my birthday life
really i don't even remember they were
just sitting on my desk all right all
right just because i don't get a chance
to go we could literally walk there so
it's so interesting that you guys got me
that for my birthday present
thank you family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family why are we doing
this over and over again family family
family
shut up yeah that was
all right sit down well this has been a
family's reunion it was fun yes and
love's got uh monarchs floating around
his uh screen there they're they're
for you
love it we've saved so many they're just
flying around in sweden for christ's
sake
well my mom
thank you
to my dad thank you our pleasure i know
where to find them where can they find
you what platform uh tick tock and
twitter and instagram and i'm always on
cameo shout out if you guys want to talk
to me
send me some uh
greetings and i'll answer you back
same for dad right mostly twitter and
cameos i'm still doing some cameos so
feel free to reach out accordingly
by the way my mom is such a big shock
cameo or yeah she's such a big shot
cameo you're meeting with like staff
from cameo and [ __ ] they take you out to
lunch yeah they just flew out of here
well she's gonna fly out to to come to
me
no she didn't
no she didn't maybe
but she's very sweet
all right well anyway thanks for
watching um
uh we'll be we'll see you guys on friday
he's not
friends i said family oh okay okay said
family
you know
thank you ethan all right happy birthday
to you on sunday
families families families families
families and families
families families families families
families families families families
families
families families families families
families